ja die aktuellen corona zahlen in dieser
krise ist es doch entscheiden diese
zahlen zu kennen denn anhand dieser
zahlen muss die regierung dann die
korona regeln beschließen aber unsere
regierung die kennt die waren corinna
zahlen derzeit nicht wie viele menschen
infizieren sich eigentlich gerade wo und
wie schlimm erkranken sie und wie viele
davon mit der nikon variante andere
länder haben diese informationen bei uns
in deutschland aber sieht das so aus ja
das ist das robert-koch-institut sie
haben gerade schon gesehen diesen
hinweis auf der website war es mal
wieder dort warnt dass es eben nur ein
unvollständiges bild der lage gibt wie
vor einem jahr immer noch also die
regierung kennt immer noch die wahren
corona zahlen nicht und das wird sich
hier leider auch erst mal nicht ändern
frühestens in der zweiten januarwoche
werde es wieder genaue zahlen geben sagt
das so weit koch institut das heißt
deutschland ist noch mindestens zehn
tage lang im koma zahlen für ein
wahnsinn die regierung kennt die zahlen
nicht das ist auch für uns alle ein
riesenproblem denn schon am 17 januar
wollen regierung und ministerpräsidenten
die neuen core ohne regeln beschließen
obwohl auch dann noch niemand die wahren
zahlen kennt das ist frustrierend und
das ist ehrlich gesagt auch nicht mehr
zu erklären
vor allem auch weil andere länder diese
waren zahlen ja auch haben schauen sie
mal hier wie das in großbritannien zum
beispiel aussieht da gibt es aktuell
diese kurven mit drin natürlich alle
aktuellen omikron fälle also halten wir
fest so geht es auch deutschland gegen
muster gesundheitsminister gerade die
zahlen schätzen sandra karl lauterbach
sagt die inzidenz könnt so zwei drei mal
höher liegen als derzeit angegeben also
wie gesagt das ist eine schätzung das
muss man sich mal geben der
bundesregierung unsere regierung die die
waren corinna zahlen weiterhin nicht
kennt darüber sprechen wir jetzt mit dem
biologen professor klaus stöhr der uns
zugeschaltet ist schönen guten tag
schönen guten morgen herr schöntag der
meinung ist dass der unlösbare aufgabe
nach über zwei jahren corona krise
verlässliche corona zahlen zu liefern ja
es gibt ja einige länder die beweisen
dass das keine unlösbare aufgabe ist
dieses diese daten wüste hat zwei
komponenten das eine ist die der
aktuellen zahlen das hat deutschland
natürlich auch nur jede schwierigkeit zu
überwinden die daten kriegt bei den
ländern und wider von realismus ist hier
eigentlich nicht sehr hilfreich dass er
erhält dann die daten aber man hätte
sicherlich schon vor einigen jahren und
jahrzehnten sich überlegen können wie
schafft man das in krisen die dort nun
auch ein zuverlässiges datenbeschaffung
analyse und dann auch bewertungssystem
zu etablieren also das hat man vorschlag
der zweite teil dieser daten wüste ist
aus meiner sicht noch viel schlimmer
nämlich es gibt keinen
bewertungssystemen die maßnahmen
analysiert zu ihrer effizienz wie
wirksam ist die klare töne wie viel
fälle kann man mit kontakt
nachverfolgung auch verhindern wie gut
ist ist die grenzschließungen bei der
reduktion der einzige punkt an und
ergebnis eine lange liste von
begleitenden wissenschaftlichen
untersuchungen die man von anfang an
hätte etablieren müssen um zu wissen wo
an welcher stelle der effizienz man sich
bewegt und das ist meines erachtens
sogar noch der schwierige und
schlechtere teil und da liegt uns liegt
england jetzt bietet neue daten publik
man zur unbekannt und südafrika mit
einer tollen publikationen für
den auswirkungen von omikron ein ganzes
stück vor deutschland aber eher stören
lassen sie uns mal ganz schön auf den
ersten teil auch schauen sie haben
gesagt die daten werden nicht wichtig
übermittelt oder nicht so häufig
übermittelt na klar ist es gerade
weihnachtspause zwischen den jahren der
arbeiten viele menschen nicht fahren
halt gerne im urlaub aber müsste man
nicht sagen wirklich in der pandemie
gibt es kein urlaub da muss jeder arbeit
wir arbeiten auch alle wir wollen helfen
wir wollen das weiter entwickeln wir
wollen die richtigen zahlen haben woran
star natürlich muss man langfristig
vorbereiten das ist ja wie offene
intensivstation oder wie bei der s-bahn
in berlin ihr plant man lange voraus und
überlegt nicht wie man unter solchen
bedingungen dann auch den betrieb am
laufen hält und das bedeutet
krisen-management langfristigen
vorbereitung auch interaktionen die
nicht unbedingt auf gesetzlicher
grundlage erfolgen es ja auch schwierig
wie gesagt in den föderalismus
diese daten dann auch zuverlässig
einzufordern aber das muss man vorher
eben durch kollaborationen durch
anbieten von lösungen durch gemeinsame
vorbereitung überwinden und das ist
offensichtlich nicht erfolgt das lka hat
natürlich auch einen schweren stand
alles auf die institution schieben das
ist eben die bundesregierung und des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums
nicht auf dauer etwas vorbereiten müssen
in anderen ländern hat man dann andere
möglichkeiten aber auch andere planung
und krisen management
optionen ausgewählt ja auch weil man die
erfahrung aus dem vergangenen jahr schon
hatte weihnachten kam diesmal ja nicht
ganz so überraschend ehrlicherweise
wie ist das jetzt mit dieser schätzung
von bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach der sagt er heute über daumen
gepeilt sage ich jetzt mal die inzidenz
müsste so zwei bis dreimal höher liegen
als derzeit angegeben er hat dazu
natürlich daten mit seinem hinterkopf
vergleichswerte aus dem ausland aus dem
benachbarten ländern dabei wie seriös
ist es dann so eine schätzung anzugeben
ja ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen wenn ich
hier mit dem auto fahren und ich war der
tank reicht gleich noch verhandelt
kilometer und 100 kilometer dann gibt
ist das schon ein signifikanter
unterschied also das sollte man solche
sachen sollte man tunlichst vermeiden in
dieser größenordnung sind ja echt nicht
prozent unterschied hierbei aber lassen
sie mich noch mal zurückkommen auf die
frage was müsste man jetzt eigentlich
unternehmen worauf müsste man sich
vorbereiten und das ist die frage wie
schlimm könnte es nach silvester kommen
die omikron variante wird nicht weiter
ausbreiten was vergessen würde ist das
immer ein weltweit auch wegfällt
begonnen und diese daten denn eigentlich
entscheiden jetzt die inzidenz gar nicht
so wichtig jetzt müsste man wissen wie
viele fälle omikron
erkrankter kommen dann ins krankenhaus
die schon von denen brauchen eine
ventilation wie sie von den müssen auf
die eu und wie viele von denen werden
sterben und die zahlen liegen aus
südafrika vor dir liegen auch aus der
england vor die kann man sicherlich
partiell großem umfang auch
extrapolieren auf deutschland und jetzt
müsste man sich vorbereiten was man
macht dann im januar ja und da glaube
ich liegt der größte
mangel den ich sehe hier mussten die
daten auf den genutzt werden aus dem
ausland exportiert werden aus
deutschland und dann muss man nicht
überlegen es hat eine ungefähr 4 fache
erhöhung der fälle geben durch um die
konnte im vergleich der delta aber es
gibt nur ein viertel so viel
krankenhauseinweisung also die
krankenhauseinweisungen insgesamt
während höchst auf demselben niveau
bleiben aber aus südafrika oder england
jetzt zahlen die zeigen dass 70 prozent
derjenigen die auf stehen die stationen
kommende leichter und oder die
langläufer mit so was richtig leichteren
von der aufnahmen kein ob sie keinen
sauerstoff brauchen nicht in die
einzigen müssen wurde die sterbefälle
auf den auf diese veränderte situation
leider nicht mit auf der grundlage runde
hat nur aus deutschland sondern aus dem
ausland muss man sich jetzt vorbereiten
und die maßnahmen dann auch entsprechend
vorbereiten dass sie auch umgesetzt
werden kann dass man nicht wieder die
noten rausholt wie das panik orchester
und dann die bei alpha und byebye
blätter sondern dass man real auf der
evidenz basierend auch handeln kann aber
wir brauchen die zahl natürlich
schnellstmöglich denn am 17 januar
findet ja schon die nächste
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz statt da
werden dann neue maßnahmen beschlossen
vielleicht verschärfungen vielleicht
aber auch entlastungen aufgrund dann
falscher oder nicht aussagekräftiger
zahlen wie kann das sein
ja es ist ja nicht so ungewöhnlich dass
einige maßnahmen auf schwacher daten
basis erfolgt sind die gutachten wie
erstellt wurden in deutschland für das
bundesverfassungsgericht die
wissenschaftlichen als die evaluiert
haben ob die intervention gerechtfertig
zwar nur nicht waren alles analog
schluss es gibt aus deutschland sehr
wenige daten die zeigen wie die der
sogenannten non formation intervention
also kontakt beschränkung und so weiter
auch wirken und so lange man diese
begleitenden wissenschaftlichen
untersuchungen verbindet mit den nicht
verbinden kann mit den aktuellen daten
sowie das jetzt über weihnachten
silvester passiert ist es natürlich
unheimlich schwer
verhältnismäßige maßnahmen und hinterher
zu bewerten ob sie dann auch irgendeine
wirkung haben also es gibt doch jetzt in
deutschland zum beispiel keine daten die
belegen wie wird das in die quarantäne
mit wievielen fälle kann man verhindern
mit einer kontakt beschränkung also das
sind ja auch alles wichtige dinge wenn
jetzt die politiker sagen wir wollen und
ab beschränkung wir wollen wieder quandt
verkürzen doch verlängert ja wir sind
fälle haben wir denn dann verhindern ist
dass jeder nur zwei bis dreifach mal
soviel ungefähr oder ist eine emotionale
frage oder können wir das am starten
konnten da glaube ich ist eigentlich der
wichtigste teil den man in deutschland
wirklich über viele jahre sie hat ende
gleich vergessen hat die biologische
forschung begleiten für die intervention
das würde jedes unternehmen anders
machen das muss auch jede regierung
anders machen so kann man nicht nur ein
unternehmen nicht führen sondern
eigentlich auch ein land nicht vielen
dank an den virologen klatschte heute
bei bild live die regierung die nach wie
vor die wahren corona zahlen nicht kennt
das ist weiter thema hier weil uns bei
bild live und darüber wollen wir auch
sprechen jetzt mit bayerns fdp- chef
martin hagen schönen guten tag herr
hagen die region kennt die wahren corona
zahlen immer noch nicht letztes jahr
lief schon genauso dieses jahr wieder so
möglicherweise erst in zehn tagen haben
wir wieder realistische zahlen auf dem
schreibtisch wer verantwortet dass die
laster
das ist in den letzten zwei jahren in
der verantwortung von bund und ländern
gewesen wir haben auf seiten der
bundesebene erlebt dass offenbar die
datenbasis für nicht so relevant
gefunden wurde dass man alles getan hat
um hier eine ordentliche erfassung
verarbeitung der zahlen hinzubekommen
wir haben drastische grundrechts
einschränkungen erlebt bis hin zum
lockdown mit ausgangssperren und
schulschließungen und das auf einer
datenbasis die dafür total ungeeignet
ist und ich fürchte dass wir das jetzt
bei der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
wieder erleben ich halte den zeitpunkt
sind der januar für die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz für total
ungeeignet denn bevor wir ein
realistisches bild der lage haben bevor
diese melde verfüge über die feiertage
abgearbeitet sind kann eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz eigentlich
nichts beschließen aber die jetzt noch
mehr zu verzögern wäre natürlich auch
das falsche signal man hätte einfach
jetzt auch zwischen den jahren auch
während weihnachten natürlich viel mehr
arbeiten müssen oder was ist ihre
meinung ja natürlich wir sind in einer
existenziellen krise und trotzdem macht
der öffentliche gesundheitsdienst nach
wie vor weihnachtsferien das war letztes
jahr schon der fall wir haben letztes
jahr ja dramatisch steigende zahlen über
die feiertage gab das hat sich dann
alles erst im januar abgebildet in den
offiziellen zahlen das zeigt natürlich
dass die prioritätensetzung ihr komplett
falsch ist das liegt aber nicht an den
menschen die in den gesundheitsämtern
arbeiten die machen ja nur den job den
man ihnen aufgibt sondern das liegt an
der mangel so nahe ausstattung und das
liegt natürlich auch daran die
gesundheitsämter immer noch häufig nicht
auf einem angemessenen stand der
digitalisierung sind das bundesweite
system sommers das ja eine zentrale
schnittstelle für diese daten sein soll
das wird jedenfalls in bayern immer noch
in fast der hälfte der gesundheitsämter
nicht angewendet und das zeigt natürlich
wo hier die defizite liegen wir arbeiten
im öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst immer
noch mit methoden der 90er jahre aber
das tolle ist ja sie können es jetzt mit
aufräumen in der bundesregierung herr
hagen ihre minister sie sind jetzt da
zuständig für die digitalisierung sie
stellt zwar nicht den
gesundheitsminister sie stellt aber den
digital minister sie stellen auch falls
es irgendwelche rechtlichen probleme
gibt den justizminister sie stellen auch
noch falls es am geld scheitern den
finanzminister als sie können richtig
aufräumen bis wann haben sie das mit dem
rest der regierung beseitigt dieses
daten desaster
es wird in dieser regierung nicht am
geld scheitern und ich freue mich dass
die bundesregierung die neue haben will
jetzt auch schon als eine der ersten
amtshandlung beschlossen hat dass
endlich mal valide zahlen auf den tisch
kommen zur frage wie viele geimpfte wie
viele ungeimpfte liegenden auf den
intensivstationen es ist ja ein unding
dass das zwei jahre dauert bis man mal
so eine übersicht dann überhaupt
erstellen dass diese zahlen kommen jetzt
auch im januar also ich denke das wird
die neue bundesregierung mit karl
lauterbach als gesundheitsminister und
der fdp die ihr um das ressort
digitalisierung sich kümmert sehr sehr
schnell angehen und das ist auch
entscheidend denn gute politische
entscheidungen kann man nur treffen auf
basis guter daten und diese daten fehlen
uns komplett fehlen uns zum beispiel
auch in bayern wir haben hier erst
jüngst die affäre gehabt dass das
landesamt für gesundheit völlig falsche
incidents zahlen herausgegeben hat zur
frage wie verteilen sich die instanzen
auf geimpften und ungeimpften auf basis
dieser völlig falschen zahlen werden
dann maßnahmen wie zweig oder auch die
diskussion um eine impfpflicht geführt
und wenn wir als opposition sagen wir
wollen die echten zahlen haben mauert
die regierung wir haben diese zahlen bis
heute nicht wir werden im zweifel vors
verfassungsgericht ziehen damit markus
söders behörde endlich die zahlen
ausdrückt das ist die kritik an bayern
noch einmal ganz kurz nachgefragt weil
das meine frage war er hagen bis wann
muss dieses datendesaster aufgelöst sein
bis wann müssen wir verlässliche zahlen
haben
im grunde muss das innerhalb weniger
wochen passieren aber sie müssen auch
das natürlich personal und digitale
infrastruktur in behörden sich nicht von
heute auf morgen direkt verbessern
lassen aber das muss eine priorität sein
für die bundesregierung ich finde es
inakzeptabel wenn auf basis von so
unsicheren daten jetzt neue maßnahmen
beschlossen werden gerne die mpk eine
woche nach hinten verschieben und bis
dahin alles tun damit die echten zahlen
auf dem tisch liegen damit man auf einer
soliden grundlage einer soliden daten
grundlage dann auch wirksame
entscheidungen treffen kann denn wir
brauchen endlich wirksame maßnahmen um
dieser pandemie hat zu werden und nicht
immer diese aktionistischen aktionen die
die freiheit der bürger einschränken
aber gegen das virus tatsächlich oft
sehr wenig ausrichten heran was sie
allerdings hier und heute versprechen
könnten und auch müssten ist dass das
chaos zumindest im nächsten winter also
nächstes jahr ausbleibt können sie das
ich kann nicht für die bundesregierung
sprechen weil ich ja nicht angehöre aber
ich kann ihnen versprechen dass das bei
karl lauterbach in guten händen ist und
dass das auch bei volker wissing unserem
digital minister in guten händen ist
also für die fdp kann ich sagen ist das
eine absolute priorität wir dürfen
nächstes jahr nicht noch einmal so ein
desaster erleben ist dieses jahr dabei
war und da wird die bundesregierung auch
alles tun was in ihrer macht steht das
hängt aber natürlich auch immer wieder
an den landesregierung das ist im
föderalismus so bund und land müssen da
hand in hand arbeiten
und ich hoffe dass das auch in bayern
verstanden wird sie machen politik in
bayern herr hagen herzlichen dank für
das gespräch mit ihnen